I think first of all, it should be brief.
Being succinct and direct about what you're looking for, what you can offer...
...and why we should consider you for the opportunity.
I want to know that the person can write, can compose.
The other thing is it gives me a better idea about, "Do I want to read the resume?"
The cover letter should tell me why you like our company, what you're looking for...
...and how your skills translate to what we need.
Explain why you're interested in that particular job, that's incredibly important.
We want to make sure that you have actually looked into the position and into the company.
And that there's something you're bringing to the job that no one else is.
What I'm most interested is how can you contribute to the success of our company.
So make sure that you articulate that in the letter, it's about what you can do.
Show some enthusiasm or passion around why the position is right for you.
It's a letter that is going to go into the "keep" stack as opposed to the "defer" stack.